Спочатку
ти прокидаєшся
Це трошки ближче береш те що тобі
потрібно для роботи
та виїжджаєш до Салтова де приходиш або
перепливаєш водосховище
Ось таким чином ми
їздимо на роботу приїжджаємо на власних
автівках потім ми залишаємо їх тут і
коли є великий мінус 10 та більше і та
замерзає вода ми переходимо на інший бік
і там їдемо на автобусі чи на
автівках які знайдемо або які приїхали
за нами зазвичай на автобусі
[музика]
Я родом з Луганської області з Луганська
Мені 26 років
Мені 25 років з вовчанська я тут виросла
я тут народилась і працюю у нас
раніше вікова категорія до війни була
35-40 років
спочатку війни багато працівників
поліції хтось звільнився хтось перейшов
на бік ворога і залишились
25 27 до 30 років
це декілька раз на добу
від двох разів до
7-8 обстрілів
наша робота така що як і в інших слідчих
в Україні Ми
забираємо докази
ведемо кримінальне провадження
реєструємо їх закриваємо їх також і
передаємо до суду рекомендуємо всі
злочини про проти цивільних проти їх
майна
і все що з цим пов'язано 125 сьогодні
експерименты
Белый колодязь вызов повреждением домов
постійно йде потік матеріалу який ми
ледь встигаємо закінчувати оформлювати
та інше постійно ти береш з собою додому
Ти дописуєш щось там щось дочитує Що
знаходиш щось формуєш І ти завжди в цій
родині і підтримував реально тут дуже
мало навкруги смерті та одні пошкодження
[музика]
баба
коли дивишся фільми про війну до
воєнного часу здається що це дуже
страшно І не уявляєш себе в такий
обстановці коли ти живеш в даній
обстановці кожного дня то ти вже не
звертаєш на це уваги
можливо організм зсередини якось на цей
реагує наприклад
шию защемила або ще щось Але мені
здається що я ніяк на це не реагую
ззовні
трішки дьорнулася і все
310 см
Я думаю Міна
були в хаті почули Вибіг сильний двері
були на свічинені в хату
Ну як голову затулила присіла і чую скло
посипалося ну дай Ми не бачили Ми
вибігли в первый вибух остався отам десь
ну це так я ж кажу що дим чорний пішов і
ми на автори і вскочили в підвал хотя
Ніна викликала поліцію сусідка ми
викликали
мене руки трусяться Я не знаю що мені
буде в мене істерика Я не знаю що мені
робити Ну неожидано все це так
получилося моментально Я тільки
наколотила чаю думаю поп'ю
крім городу тут нікого немає тут немає
ніякої техніки ніяких
військовослужбовців
Нема навіть критичного інфраструктури
яку полюбляють росіяни Можливо вони
хотіли поцілитися в кукурудзи Я не знаю
якщо цей був якийсь так би мовити
прильот як ми збираємо матеріал
який можна буде
застосовувати от доказування в
подальшому проти країн агресора
це огляд місця події фіксування за
допомогою фото відео апаратури
самих прильотів пошкоджень домоволодінь
пошкоджень будинків транспортних засобів
тілесних ушкоджень в людей Також ми
збираємо оцю довідки
допитумо їх в якості потерпілих в якості
свідків
77 за національністю
[музика]
24:30 а не в 8 часов уже были
подразделам У нас евакуировали в Старый
Салтов Вот как раз
жу выбило старая база и начальник родила
растерялся естественно
уехал до
лго команду решать а саме для себя кто
куда кто на Харьков кто назад на
волчанск я поехал
після окупації
дуже багато людей знайомих повиїжджала
за кордон
населення із 18 тисяч зараз 3 або 4
мігрує тисячі і немає зовсім знайомих
залишилося лише люди похилого віку
мало молодих
тут людей зовсім немає так сказати 24
лютого о восьмій годині військові РФ
зайшли до відділу поліції нашого А
купували як мені пізніше стало відомо
вже коли я виїжджала з окупації нам
розповідали що тут
селилися військові і в них були казарми
Вони повністю зруйнували всі меблі
стіни
пошкодили вікна також багато рам з вікон
Вони пошкоджені І взагалі це райвідділ
Ну не зовсім придатний до умов внесення
служби тому що потрібно нести службу тут
24/7 Тут немає опалення світло пропадає
тому умови і а також немає води у нас
немає іншого вибору
нам потрібно десь працювати тут працюємо
тут
бойові в нас далеко не максимальні і
навіть не середні тобто якось так і ми
витрачаємо багато що своїх коштів на це
на ці переїзди на ремонт своїх автівок
на
те коли ми
намагаємося ремонтувати гуму на колесах
оскільки вона постійно пробивається
через осколки
я себе не вважаю героєм тому що це
Професія це ж не
якась це не якесь досягнення ми робимо
свою роботу Кожного дня
[музика]
На цьому я вважаю що
керівництво
країни-агресора цієї терористичної
країни
навіть не країна утворення яка
схожа на країну воно буде
притягненою до відповідальності
обов'язково це відбудеться
Це просто треба вірити і
намагатися приблизити це якомога скоріше
як був
трибуналбурзі
так і ми повинні зробити свої
нюрбург мабуть десь на території України